one of the questions I had was do more
viral particles mean that you end up
with more antibodies and therefore
better protection so that's a theory so
you're assuming that the more viruses
you have the more antibodies that needs
to be produced in order to attack that
virus and I think that also have to do
with how much your body is fighting
against an infection so you can assume
that the higher viral particles that are
in your body the more immune system has
to work to pump out those antibodies to
take on that infection cool so I have a
question this question is actually
coming from my cousin Katie Katie thanks
for waiting I miss seeing everybody I'm
glad that we were able to do this on
zoom' and her question is will this be
able to detest be able to detect whether
or not people are carriers of koban 19
or SARS Coby - and also do carriers
carry antibodies as well so that's a
good question so carrier probably
meaning that people are asymptomatic so
you have the virus you're not showing
anything on the thing with carriers
carriers usually just hold on to that
particular virus or infection I'm in a
case of size close to I think your body
does eventually clear it but it seems
that people who are in a symptomatic may
not have as much antibodies present so
usually what causes someone to become
really sick is like your aunt your
immune system is working really hard to
pump up these antibodies because you
have an attack on your system and so
this test can see if it's that's one be
able to see if you are carrier but it
can see if you've recovered from that
illness what you'll need to test to see
if your carrier fear is symptomatic is
that previous test I can look at if you
actually have a current viral infection
all right so another same question and
this is will it be seasonal that's a
good question I think we're all trying
to figure that out now the thing with
this corn Avars and it's like kind of
fascinating but not really but like as a
scientist you're like seeing all this
data coming out
and it's like not anything that we've
all expected or seen from other viruses
so it's really hard to tell I think it
was a paper that came out showing that
this virus can actually still replicate
and spread in warmer weather and so I
don't know if seasonal would be the
right word because there are other
countries that are in tropical regions
that also do have outbreaks and it
doesn't seem to be slowing down until
you take the measures of social adjust
social distance in our isolation um so
we're still trying to figure it out that
would be nice that it like goes away for
a bit and like gives us some time to
like figure out how we can come up with
these tests and make sure that we're
prepared the next time but the honest
answer is that we're not sure yet all
right so I have a question from Facebook
so thanks to everybody joining us in
from Facebook what are the chances of
someone getting the virus again and how
would we know that the virus is out of
somebody's system without hagwa if they
don't have symptoms in the ever so you
wouldn't know that's the thing about
people being asymptomatic it's like you
can walk around like I have a little
cough I'm fine right and you walk around
you don't know if one it's something
else or it's our scope - that's causing
that but what was the previous question
before that it is what are the chances
of really infection so right now there
are studies that are showing that you
can't get me infected with the virus but
I also want to point out that these
viruses are really adaptable to their
new environment so there are a lot of
random mutations that are happening and
God forbid that happens to a point where
he changes it completely where our body
now does not recognize that antigen or
the surface proteins you can say that
someone can get reinfected with a
different strain of the sim of the same
virus and so right now there studies
that are showing that this virus doesn't
actually mutate us quickly as say to flu
so every year you kind of need a flu
vaccine and it changes so frequently
this virus seems to mutate at a slower
rate which is good news for scientists
and also good news for you immune system
meaning that that recognition antibodies
that are produced can keep you protected
forever of some length of time okay so
this is kind of related to that and the
question is are different strains of
code are there different strains of
koban 19 I guess actually we're talking
about the virus itself and if so would
this have any effect on the antibody
test being developed that's also a very
good question so there's a really nice
site called next strain and so it goes
in and inputs all I did Natick data all
this the corona viruses that we've taken
from humans who've been infected and I
think the word strain we need to be more
cognizant of so just because like a
random mutation takes place it's not
enough to consider it a new strain if
that makes sense so a lot of mutations
have to happen in order for that to
occur um scientifically yes it can
happen that these new strains are
evolving and they are showing that they
are multiple strains going around right
now I think in the beginning there were
two strains L&S I think they called it
but the good news is it's showing that
one strain is not worse than the other
um so they're operating the same and I
think that's kind of good news but the
question does lens like is that the
reason why there are people who are
asymptomatic or have four symptoms the
honest answer is like we're not sure
right now but what we've been doing
there's a really nice database that I've
talked about that you know doctors can
and scientists can input that genetic
data and we have really good technology
where we can map that and see how that
changes over time so yes there are
multiple strains but they are all acting
the same okay so somebody was very very
astute and noticed the difference
between I spike and M spike in turn like
I mentioned I removed a lot of the data
cuz I want it to be like as
straightforward as possible getting the
big idea out so what do you scientists
did so there are many different cell
lines that people utilize in a
laboratory to make
synthetic molecules or proteins and so
one cell cell line that scientists use
is what we call them a million cell line
and so these mammalian cell lines are
really good at taking up the genetic
sequence that we transfected in them
which basically means you like inject it
into the cell via a specific method and
then those cells then take their
machinery to pump out this protein
alongside all of the other proteins and
then you have to go through another
process to kind of separate out your
protein of interest now I spike is the
other cell lines that they use so
they're also insect cell lines I know
it's where it insects right but we can
use these insect cell lines to also
hijack their machinery to make our
protein of choice what's really nice
with these insect cell lines is that
they kind of just spit it out all right
so they make these proteins and they
spit it out into I guess the liquid
that's surrounding them and scientists
can then take that liquid and see how
much protein that they have so the
reason why we utilize different cell
lines is to see if one is more robust at
making our thing but a lot of times
certain cell lines can be like hey I
don't like this thing that you gave me
I'm just gonna cut it up or I won't even
make it so they use a mammalian cell
line which is the M and an insect cell
line which is the eye but they also
showed that the mammalian cell line was
able to give them larger amounts or
quantities of that specific Spike
protein the question very nice
so Galen asks do we have data yet that
shows how long the IgG antibodies for
Tsarskoe b2 are present in previously
infected person and would these
antibodies be present for a few months
years
how long has immunity defined so you
always would have that immunity the
question is how long would it would the
virus still be what the antibody still
recognize the virus that will come
around so if the virus doesn't change
and there's not a like a drastic change
in that virus those IgG should be able
to cut to allow that person to be immune
usually people start producing IgG
antibodies anywhere from like it's
really really large is like from seven
to thirty something days um I think
also one thing that we're missing is
that humans even though we're like 99.9%
similar that 1.1% gives us the diversity
that we see and our bodies don't all act
the same so it's really hard to see what
say what would affect one person versus
the other so it'll be kind of a question
like do we need a booster okay but yeah
I think we also need a clinical trial to
determine yeah okay so here's a great
question question from one of our rock
edu family members hi Anika thank you
for joining us
was there a discussion in terms of the
cost of this test hmm will it be offered
to folks who are uninsured I'm not sure
if this was discussed in the paper but I
think these are really important
questions these are amazing questions so
in this paper the goal of this paper was
just to develop a test so they did not
talk about like the cost of the test but
I can tell you from the two companies
that I found that are selling these FDA
non-approved tests for only
professionals so if you're like a doctor
if you have a doctor's office you can
buy these tests I think they're selling
a pack of 25 for like 350 so it's
probably around 15 dollars a test and
I'm not sure insurance company thing is
something like way over my head like I
don't know what they're doing with on
what they'll attempt to do in the future
but I know there are other countries
trying really hard to have these tests
readily available for everyone and I'm
not sure if they're putting a price on
it or they're just giving it free to
people all right so a question from a DP
which is how do scientists account for
the time lag where kovat peaks and the
time when IDG and IgM antibodies levels
reach their respective Maxima how did
you determine that time line mm-hmm so
they do this based on so when someone
gets infected what you can do is take
blood from them so if anyone's been like
I met into the hospital they usually
like take blood from me at certain
points and they can use similar tests to
see what antibodies are present based on
say like the viral antigen that's using
this test and they can take it at
several time points to see when they're
seeing that peak but like I said
everyone produces those antibodies at
different time points but I think the
consensus is around date to today seven
or eight is when most people starts
producing those IgM antibodies and then
around seven to like 30 something is
when people start producing the IgG
antibodies so the only way to know when
you're switching or if you have a
certain type is actually taking an
antibody test okay I'm going to combine
a couple of questions around mutation so
there are questions around you know do
people have sort of like variations and
East to inhibitor sorry not an ace
inhibitor ace - um and another question
is around are the regarding the mutating
capacity of the mutation capacity of the
protein spikes and um so yeah the ace
the ace 2 receptors a really cool thing
that scientists are actually looking
into there was a paper that came out
maybe a month or two ago when this kind
of started in Wuhan where they looked at
predisposition or genetic
predispositions to the ACE 2 receptor in
cells there weren't that many people in
a study but it did show that cert
certain people of certain genetic
backgrounds have different variations of
that receptor and it may be playing a
role as to who like recovers and who
doesn't do well with the virus but
they're still trying to figure out how
that variation works in terms of like is
it a genetic predisposition variation so
like are you born with it is it
something that be bellos based on like
environmental factors and I don't think
we know that as yet but they are
variation in the amount that we see on
ourselves and like I guess the sequence
of that receptor and a second question
to that is um regarding the spike
protein in the likelihood of the spike
protein mutating in the corona virus it
can happen um that's the thing with
these viruses I
I always tell people is like you know
scientists think we're like we're smart
and we can like combat these things but
honestly these viruses have been around
for millions of years before humans even
like hit Earth and so they've been able
to evolve and adapt to many many
different types of environments their
viruses for every organism on earth
there's there are millions and millions
of viruses there and they just these
mutations happen randomly they don't
really have like the checkpoint
machinery like higher organisms have
like humans and so it is likely that a
mutation can happen that changes like
the I guess you call them epitopes on
that antigen that may now trick the
immune system being like oh you thought
you were protecting against me but
actually I've changed my protein so that
you can't recognize me anymore it's a
good question so this might not be an
immune question but it's a really
curious symptom of the disease and it
asks is it true that a loss of taste and
smell may be a sign of a mild attack of
the virus and if it's true how do we
radiate regain the taste and smell and
that's finished sweetie on Facebook
there was a paper that came out that
show that this is like the symptoms for
people who have like mild symptoms where
one of the first things to go is like
your loss of taste and smell and I
remember when we saw that paper the team
and I were like can we still taste
can we still tap smell okay we're good
the thing is not everyone experienced
that but if you do experience that and
then you regain it probably that you're
recovering from that virus or you're in
a point where your antibodies are coming
where it's removing those viral
particles so someone who studies sensory
nerves I'm really curious to know if
it's a anyway I have no idea all I know
is that I am smelling everything like
like gym socks and like and like yes I
could still smell that they are
disgusting so there's a this is a really
great question that I think tells me
that people were your talk was good
and people are paying attention because
the question is can these spike proteins
be utilized in a vaccine for or against
yes yes and yes so I talked about using
the spike protein to detect antibodies
but in essence if it can detect
antibodies I could recognize that
antigen if we introduce that viral
antigen or that spike protein into
humans
our bodies are also going to produce
antibodies for that viral image and
that's how vaccinations work I think the
CDC has a page on there or another
organization where they're actually
showing some of the ways that scientists
and other companies are going about
developing the vaccine and a lot of them
are utilized in the spike protein but
there are also people who are using just
a top portion of that protein so I guess
we call that the binding domain of that
protein so the part that specifically
binds to your cell receptors and your
cells and so they're just taking that
small part and they're also showing that
you can produce antibodies towards
that's that part so yes scientists are
looking and using these spike proteins
or variations of it to use as future
vaccines
all right so this is an interesting one
is it possible that a certain blood type
would have more or less of ability to
produce antibodies it's a good question
I do not know the answer of that
question and I feel like I saw something
like that in person but I did not go
into it um so yeah I have no idea um but
I'll be really interesting to see if
people of specific blood type and I
think that's the case for certain other
things so it'll be really cool to see if
that's the case with chrono virus or
SARS close to okay so I'm gonna ask a
question of my own because I think it's
you know we have a captive audience and
what are the things that frustrates you
regarding the misconceptions of copán 19
and SARS Kobe - is there something that
you think is really important to point
out regarding you know some
pseudoscience or misinformation so we'll
be here all day if I go through each one
you know but also I think it's like a
lot of people are in denial that like
this thing can reek so much havoc right
on populations and like I mentioned
before we're really under estimating
these microorganisms right these viruses
can adopt really well to the
environments right and especially if our
bodies have never seen something like
that before it can definitely wreak
havoc so there are a lot of thoughts
about like oh like me may have
synthesized this virus in a laboratory
or like this is all a hoax and there's
no such thing as clubbin 19 and so like
it's really annoying like as a person of
like Christian beliefs where you have
like a lot of these religious
organizations saying like you know it's
like they're just like hyping this up in
news and we don't have to take part in
social distancing and then you gather
especially people who are more
susceptible to getting really ill from
these diseases and people have died with
that mindset and something something I
say is that okay if you don't believe
that's happening still regard the
guideline it's like still do the social
dislike just maybe like
there's a tiny tiny chance here right
but also if you are
it still affects us all the same and
just wash your hands for 20 seconds
distance yourself from everyone like we
mentioned like some people don't know if
they have it there in septum attic they
have really mild symptoms so I think
it's very important to not put others in
jeopardy like I have people that work in
hospital in environments that this thing
is affecting everyone it's real and I
think we're doing a disservice to
ourself when we're putting out these
theories out here that harms people
right it's it's one thing to have a
theory that oh if I drink ginger tea
every night I would never get it because
like ginger tea is not gonna kill you
it's not gonna kill the next person and
it might like help you immune system but
also don't like leave your house
drinking ginger tea thinking you can
infect someone else what about the 5g
situation do you want to oh my god yes
so there's this like conspiracy theory
about like 5 g and coronavirus and
saying that p places that have 5 g r
people that experience in the symptoms
imita coronavirus and so the reason why
we know someone has corona virus is
because we test them for the virus i'm
is called was Koch's postulates where
basically you have to identify the thing
that's causing the symptom and so how it
works is someone is sick we don't just
say like oh that person has corona virus
right if they're hospitalized right
they're having a really hard time
breeding they're actually testing for
that virus particle so one they have the
virus - there are places that does not
have 5g that are also suffering from the
virus so if that conspiracy theory was
right you'd say that
oh this country that doesn't have 5g
they're all you know not be susceptible
to have any symptoms or having the virus
so I look that's BS a home but um I said
ya know that's not the case alright so
one last question and I will take this
one from the audience this is from
Facebook and Molly Kay who asks why are
people who have had the virus and
recovered testing positive for the virus
that's a good question so there was a
recent paper talking of
how long this virus stays in different
shedding routes and so usually with the
tests we test with the nasal swabs
but it's seen that the virus can and
then so they're testing positive with
the nasal swabs and any tests negative
but if they test their poop or their
feces they're actually showing that that
person still have viral particles there
so it's like laying around the body so
they weren't technically recovered the
tests that they use was unable to detect
that in that specific passage but they
were able to test it in other shedding
routes so that's a good question I'm I
think it was like kind of weird for
people to see that but yes Dave
technically you recovered from it it
don't have the symptom but the virus is
still sitting around longer in different
parts of the body